france a soumis deux est au coeur d'une
polémique sur l'islam o'shea attendent
était d'une campagne de calomnie ce pas
une polémique s'est alors c'est la
raison parce que l'an dernier vous avez
participé à une manifestation contre
l'islamophobie sté le 10 novembre
dernier
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pourriez
redescendre dans la rue pour les mêmes
raisons contre l'islam en photo j'ai de
boucher c'est la raison de cette
manifestation était due le fait qu'un
homme qui parlait était un ancien élu du
rassemblement national avait tiré au
fusil sur une mosquée à bayonne je
manifesterai toujours pour protester
contre le fait que certains de nos
concitoyens
en raison de l'heure de leurs
convictions spirituelles de la religion
soit agresser des frères musulmans alors
synagogue et agresser je ferais pareil
ensuite aux côtés des salafistes effet
un musulman je ne sais pas de quoi vous
parlez de quoi vous parlez du ccf
d'accord alors ça n'est pas exactement
mais on va dire deux mots
alors monsieur darmanin a fait meeting
en 2013 avec le ccf est il un allié des
salafistes et des frères musulmans à
tourcoing à tourcoing monsieur delevoye
ancien ministre qui a fait une
trajectoire assignés à ce que je n'ai
jamais fait en 2015 avec le seuil est
est ce que ces demandes du gouvernement
qui ont fait meeting commun pas pour
apporter la contradiction ou qui ont
signé une tribune avec le cf sont ils
des années des salafistes
le säntis de madame boucher pendant leur
demande et demandent la dissolution est
aujourd'hui 10é n'en avez vous qu'est ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que ça rend
hommage à ces deux minutes à vide ne
m'attendais oui d'accord mais les mêmes
qui m'attaquent
si le fait d'avoir manifesté avec des
gens meurent en a c'est complètement fou
je vais vous faire un autre aveu quand
j'ai manifesté suite à l'assassinât
madame pneus assassinés parce que juive
dans cette manifestation il avait des
gens je pense à madame le pen avec lg un
désaccord total pour autant ça ne me
rend pas complice de de madame le pen
dans cette manifestation qui était
contre antisémite il des gens ont hurlé
israël vaincra en soutien au
gouvernement israélien
bon alexis 15 he has de fautes 10
dissoudre aujourd'hui le cci a joué à
choses clairement à ce stade pour après
avoir lu énormément sur le sujet y
compris tous les jours je ne vois pas
moi je ne dispose pas des éléments pour
quelle raison il faudrait 10 ou de cfa
un projet quand on a une vision de la
société qui n'est pas la mienne je vous
dire les choses très clairement tel que
je le pense c'est à dire que moi je ne
suis pas favorable à ce que
on s'organise en fonction de leur culte
pour se défendre contre une
discrimination je suis un républicain et
je suis pour des associations qui
luttent contre les discriminations et je
ne voit pas d'un bon oeil
quand les gens s'organisent pas ce que
vous voyez pour lutter uniquement par an
pendant 10 ans une association de juifs
qui lutterait contre antisémitisme bien
personnellement le replica je suis la
profanation de musulmans contre de
racisme en visite en corée c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut mais tellement
longtemps alors par amp g pas ce que
c'est et sur la non mais je voudrais
terminer là tu bandes j'ai fouillé sur
le compte twitter du ccf
ils défendent ou du moins ils se sont
opposés à la fermeture d'une école à
bobigny moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec
le ccf cette école quand destinent dans
lequel des enfants entre 3 et 10 ans
apprenez le coran je suis pour la fermer
et je fais ça ça n'est pas du racisme
anti musulman c'est pas pour ça qu'il
faut supprimer pour autant une fois que
j'ai dit tout ça à ce stade je n'ai pas
d'éléments pour savoir s'il faut et ça
me semble curieux à tel point même que
le même ministre qui disait qu'il faut
le fermer
trois jours après qu'il faut dissoudre
aplati faut que dissoudre le collectif
cheikh yacine collectif anti sémite avec
lequel moi je n'ai pas vraiment et je
suis même sidéré que ce truc là
existaient encore et que même monsieur
sefra oui le responsable du collectif
cheikh yacine pouvait même rentrer dans
un établissement scolaire
c'est le drame qui s'est passé avec
monsieur samuel pâtit sans
qu'immédiatement salert du point de vue
des renseignements territoriaux le fait
que dans mon petit semita militants
voyez ce que je veux dire et là dessus
nous éloigne ans il n'y a rien pour vous
entraîner une solution avez vous des
éléments mais vous ne savez pas vous
dites il ya pas de raison pour l'instant
dissoudre le ccf jeudi je ne dispose pas
de ces éléments c'est une affaire
sérieuse à 2,10 ou bien est ce que vous
savez dans ce pays même même mes
adversaires je ne suis pas pour qu'il
soit dissous comme ça donc je demande à
voir quels sont les éléments juridiques
et j'ai l'impression que le gouvernement
recule parce que lui aussi avait il a
pas beaucoup d'éléments
[Musique]